tras cinco años cerrado el monumento más
visitado de europa reabrir al público en
2024 este jueves la ministra de cultura
francesa visitó la catedral notó dama y
mostró su confianza en el avance de las
obras un som hace curso estamos bastante
seguros todos nosotros colectivamente de
que el año 2024 que tiene 365 días será
el año de finalización de gran parte de
esta obra en todo caso de la reapertura
de la catedral al culto y al público
auschwitz un plazo que manuel marco
había prometido en la noche del incendio
que devastó el monumento el 15 de abril
de 2019 el objetivo es ambicioso y
obligar a los obreros a trabajar
arduamente para respetar la fecha
mientras enfrentan los desafíos que
implica el proyecto
durante la fase de aseguramiento y
consolidación tuvimos que hacer frente a
grandes dificultades nos enfrentamos al
kobe 19 tuvimos ráfagas de viento que
nos obligaron a dejar de usar las grúas
hubo un cierre de la obra parte del
prefecto para readaptar toda la obra a
la presencia del plomo etc
el proyecto se encuentra ahora en la
segunda etapa de reconstrucción que será
seguida por la renovación de exterior y
terminará con el diseño de la explanada
de la catedral que depende del
ayuntamiento de parís con un presupuesto
de
850 millones de dólares el objetivo es
devolver a no jodan su esplendor y puede
regresar a acoger a los más de 12
millones de visitantes anuales